hi I'm Antonia torralva a computer
vision professor at electrical
engineering and computer science
department at MIT
and I'm going to talk about two
different projects that tackle one
particular issue we know that in machine
learning and computer vision in
particular we cannot overstate the
importance of data data is Paramount and
almost nothing works really if you don't
have a lot of data to train it
and what these two projects have in
common is that they have a common goal
which is to get rid of this need of
having a lot of data and another thing
that they have in common is that these
are ongoing lines of work it means that
we haven't reached that goal yet but I
think that the results are very
promising and hopefully you'll see that
eventually one day maybe we'll we'll
really know
we will not need data
so in computer vision in particular we
need to have a lot of data that data
also needs to be created in many cases
with labels that specify all the
different objects in scenes so that we
can train computer vision systems to
recognize objects and and and people and
animals and actions and whatever is
happening on a particular scene
then of course the community has worked
really hard in order to make
unsupervised learning work so that we
can get rid of the labels
and so now you have just a big
collection of images you might learn
interesting visual representations that
allow you to solve a lot of different
tasks without needing large amounts of
curated data which is actually very
costly to obtain
one example of a successful approach in
unsupervised learning is contrastive
learning which is capable of learning a
very useful visual representation by
just using images and learning a
representation that is able to
discriminate a
one single image against all other
images by creating an augmented set of
transformations of that particular image
like in this case this particular image
of a dog that gets augmented by
different versions of the dog by
cropping flipping changing the colors of
that image and that's the set that needs
to be discriminated against all positive
possible other images and what is really
amazing is that this type of procedures
are incredibly successful at learning
visual representations that that compete
with a fully trained uh computer
computer vision systems
but really our goal is to get rid of
images also even images are already
expensive to collect they have lots and
lots of different issues there are
privacy issues there's just costly to
collect them and collect them with the
with enough diversity
um so we really want to have systems
that ideally learn to solve tasks
without labels and without images and
okay this seems like uh kind of
challenging and crazy uh goal but what I
will be describing in this presentation
are just different versions of our
attempts of solving this particular
problem
so as I was mentioning generally
computer vision systems and machine
learning in general requires a lot of
data and we need millions of images in
order to train computer vision systems
that are capable of solving visual tasks
with pretty with pretty good performance
nowadays and the question really is how
much data is really necessary do we need
all this data can we get away with just
very very little data and does this data
need to be real you know reality is full
of problems and can we actually use data
that is not real and what type of not
real data can we use
so here is one example of a data set
that is pretty popular in computer
vision this is the Sci-Fi data set and
the first task that we had was okay you
know these data sets are pretty large
how many images do you really need can
we reduce the amount of images that this
data set contains so that
when you drain it with a smaller data
set you still achieve the same
performance
and and even more do we do these images
need to be real what if the images were
not real what if these images are well
some strange texture images that are
just synthesized to achieve the best
performance possible
so what we want to do is to compress
this particular data set that contains
10 classes into a set of supercharged
images where each image is like the ones
I'm showing here is just not a real
image it doesn't look real necessarily
in fact it does not look real at all
but it has the property that it actually
condensates all of the examples of one
particular class in one two into one
single image and the goal is that this
supercharged set of images should be
capable of reproducing the original
performance of a system train with a
full data set when it is trained only
with this small set of images
and of course we haven't really managed
to do this but I'm going to tell you the
direction in which we are going and the
steps and the progress that has been
made in this particular direction so
this is a line of work that has been
done in collaboration with uh tongsu and
George and and also uh aliosha
and
the initi the initial idea is the
following one you have a data set of
images let's say a data set that
contains 50 000 images in this case the
Sci-Fi data set that you use to train on
a neural network and what we want to do
is to run a process that we will call
data set distillation that will have the
goal of taking that data set of 50 000
images and compress it into a small data
set of 10 images so that when you train
the neural network you achieve similar
performances
there are several ways in which you can
actually do this the first time when we
started this project that was a lead by
tonsu in 2018 the idea was the following
just star you want to have a synthetic
data set so that when you train your
neural network you are going to create a
number of a trajectory in the parameter
space of the neural network and what we
wanted to do was to follow a particular
trajectory so that the end point
when you evaluate the performance on the
real data set when you evaluate the loss
on the real data set you want that loss
to be as as high as possible yeah sorry
the loss as low as possible and the
performance as high as possible and then
what you do is you just back propagate
to the synthetic data set and you change
the synthetic images so that you improve
the loss the sector require expensive to
do because you need to run back
propagation through all the different
stages that you are running of of
training that you're running in order to
obtain the parameters of the network so
this process is kind of expensive
and the first attempts were not very
successful the paper got rejected from
all the major conferences
um
but a lot of people got excited by this
uh by this idea and started working on
developing better versions of this
particular task of data set distillation
and in fact there have been a number of
papers that had come along showing that
there is actually quite a lot of Promise
in that in that particular area of work
so here is our latest
approach in order to solve this task
which now works fairly well still not it
still doesn't work as well as the real
data itself but it's getting quite close
so here is how it works
so you start with uh with a real data
set that you're going to use to train
your neural network
as you train it
each time that you run one step of back
propagation you are going to move along
the space of parameters you are going to
follow a particular trajectory and what
you will do what we do here is just run
this process multiple times by having
multiple different random
initializations which will give rise to
different trajectories in parameter
space and we store all of those
trajectories
so now what we will do is we want to
generate a synthetic data set so that it
learns to reproduce these trajectories
so what we will do is we will start at
some random time T we'll take some of
one of the parameters that we learn from
real data at one particular iteration
one random iteration in our data set of
trajectories and then what we will do is
we will run M steps and steps of bug
propagation using this synthetic data
set
and the laws will be that we want the
parameters at the lab last step in this
particular small piece of a trajectory
we want that to be as close as possible
to the parameters that were obtained by
the real trajectory when we were just in
real data starting on the same
initialization
and what we'll do is to create then back
propagate
through all of these different uh
updates
so that we update the synthetic data set
and we will do this for multiple initial
uh points so we'll have a lot of
different points in our synthetic
trajectories and we will then just
initialize this in different points and
back propagate by optimizing this loss
so that we optimize this particular set
of images
and then at each step we'll get a refine
set of synthetic data
so what do these supercharged images
look like
well here is an example of one of the
categories in imagenet in this case it
contains penguins and when you compress
this particular set of images into a
single image that tries to achieve the
same performance in this particular case
this image what it's trying to do is to
achieve is to produce the same type of
learning trajectories in parameter space
when it is used to train your system
using back propagation so what the image
supercharged image looks like is this
so this is a single image that
summarizes the entire class of images
that contain penguins and here what you
can see is that this image okay doesn't
look real at all it looks a little bit
texture and it actually seems to contain
multiple versions of the Penguins there
seems to be like different bodies and
maybe superimposed Penguins looking in
different directions and this is me this
seems to be like a good summary of this
particular class of images
and it's actually quite nice to look at
the supercharged images they look no to
my eyes they look really beautiful here
there is for instance the class of
cheeseburger hot dogs pretzels pizza so
this is the subset of images of classes
from imagenet that that refer to food
and you can see that they seem to be
some sort of combination of different
poses and different uh styles of the
different object classes object objects
that compose the part this particular
class you know like the hot dog class
now it seems to have like multiple hot
dogs superimposing some strange way
and that seems to be enough to provide
to the to the learning algorithm with
enough diversity in one single image to
learn about different poses of the of
the images that you may encounter in the
real world
here is the same thing for dogs
this is fruits
here is the same theme but for Cipher
which is this a smaller data set that
contains the images just a 32 by 32
there are 10 classes here there are the
10 compressed
supercharged images when you compress
the data set into one single image per
class but you can also do other things
you can also increase the number of
images we could supercharge more images
for instance here
we are supercharging all the images in
each class into a data set that contains
10 images per class
so here you can see that there is a
little bit more of diversity each
supercharged image now seems to instead
of considering all the poses and
appearances that an object class might
have it seems to be kind of grouping
them into different canonical poses and
still within each of those it adds
enough diversity to compare to to learn
something else about the possible
appearances and changes imposed Still
Still within that cluster
here is the same thing but constrained
to be 50 images per class of course as
you increase the number of images per
class computational cost will also grow
but here you can see also you know if we
focus on one particular class and for
instance the cars here they are the 50
images you can see that each
supercharged image looks more real now
but still it's not a real image the
texture in the background is like a
mixture of all different possible
backgrounds that each cluster might have
but it gives you a sense of what are the
biases on that data set now for instance
here there seems to be a lot of red cars
now there seems to be there is a
condensing some of the supercharged
images to contain a lot of different
variations of redness
foreign
but at the end the question is how far
are we how far are we in condensing all
of the images from a data set into a
single image or a few images so that we
reproduce the performance of the
original data set so here what I'm
showing is two plots that summarize
performance on cfar 100 and the tiny
images uh 10 images imagenet which is a
small reduced version of imagenet and
the yellow bar is the data is the
performance that you get when you train
with a full data set
so in this particular case you can see
that cfar is around 55 recognition rate
while tiny imagenet is around 38 or so
so now what happens when we use the
synthetic data set that contains this
supercharged images
and here are the results what I'm
showing here is in blue is the
performance of the model that I
described a moment ago by mimicking the
gradient trajectories the the back
propagation trajectories followed during
training on the real data set and in red
is another competing data set that
appears a different competing approach
that appear at the same time
and what you can see is that when you
charge just one image per class
performances are fairly low much better
than chance in fact uh in in our model
with the blue bar you can see that the
performance is almost a third of the
performance achieved by the original
data set which is quite amazing given
the fact that you are using just one
single image per class
and when we compress the data set into
50 images per class you can see the
performance Gap becomes really small and
these are data sets done this
compression Factor reduces the data set
to around one percent of the original
data set size so it's a pretty heavy
compression
there are also a lot of applications for
this type of approaches being able to
condense a single data set into few
images people have been using this to
study privacy Federated learning
continual learning neural architecture
search and there are many other
possibilities that you know one could
use this type of approach in order to
build to build different applications
so another thing that we can do I just
want to briefly mention another
different type of application which is
we can also condense the images into a
single image
but it's larger than the original images
themselves so that when you crop you
know when you crop this image you obtain
different types of images supercharged
images that we can use for training so
this will be like putting lots of images
into single texture
the idea now will be that when you have
your real data set you can replace this
by a single image that is much larger so
that when you crop this image in
different ways you obtain also you can
reproduce the performances of the
original training set
and here is an example of what happens
these are the supercharged images when
we're using just a single image as
before but now when we use this larger
texture that you can crop this is what
you get for the same classes you can see
that some of the images are quite fun to
to look at like the Penguins now it
seems to have different sorts of
appearances as you look at different
locations in the image here is the
fruits when you go from a normal image
to this larger image what you get is
something that looks like a texture that
contains like different appearances of
these objects they look again they look
kind of interesting so now what can you
do with this well if you have an object
class like a parrots here you can
compress this into a tileable texture
and now you can use this texture to make
clothing and now you can wear your own
data set
so this is just another application of
being able to compress a single data set
into a texture now you can wear your
data set and you know you are carrying
it with you
so in this first part what I was talking
was about you know compressing a data
set into a few supercharged images and
these supercharged images they don't
look real anymore they look kind of they
are strange textures
but the problem is that this you know
even creating these supercharged images
still requires using real images so can
we really get rid of real images and
train visual systems with no images and
labels at all
so do we really need any images
so we have seen that uh contrastive
learning can be used for instance to
learn very useful visual representations
and then you use that visual
representation to solve different tasks
like for instance image classification
that you can do by just having a linear
layer at the at the output of your
visual representation
and the question then is how do you get
these weights
you can use real images like in the case
of contrastive learning but what else
what else can you do in order to get
these weights so that you don't need to
use real images
so I'm going to show some of the results
first let me just tell you a little bit
what is the Benchmark that we will use
we are going to use imagenet 100
classification test this is a small
version of imagenet that allows us to
train and test systems much more quickly
than by just using the original imagenet
it contains 100 classes here they are
and the task is just to classify to
classify one input image according to
one of these 100 possible classes so
it's just another way of being able to
do a larger scale experiments without
requiring the amount of gpus that
generally you know requires working with
imagenet so we hope that these data sets
will also become useful
um so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to develop different ways of training a
neural network without images
so the first way that you could train a
neural network with no images is not to
train it at all so one thing that you
can do is you take your neural network
there is this defined but some set of
weights and those weights generally when
you start training you initialize them
randomly
so one thing that you can do is that's
it you just have your random
initialization and don't do anything
else to it
that will create a visual representation
is not going to be very powerful but
it's going to be somewhat useful
and now you can just train on top of it
no a linear layer a linear classifier to
do the final classification task in this
case it will be trained to solve the
imagenet 100 classification task
so what I'm showing here are marked with
the arrow is the performance that you
get when you use a confnet train not
train actually just using random weights
and the vertical axis denotes the
performance so here the performance is
around 21 recognition rate chance is one
percent so this is much much better than
chance
um but of course of course it's not very
good
on the other stream we will have
performances that you get when you use
real images but just to make it you know
uh fair for us we are going to use real
images from a different data set than
imagenet so that we have an upper bound
to the performance that we get with real
images without knowing the biases of the
data set so in this case we are using
places we'll we'll Train A visual
representation using places and then
test it on imagineer 100 and we get
around 55 percent performance in
recognition rate
so these two red lines represent the
words we can do using no training at all
and and what is our upper bound when we
use real images that have no knowledge
about the final task that we wanted to
perform so what I'm going to do now is
think about different ways of training
neural networks without real data and
see how we close the gap how we move in
performances before between these two
lines and what we'll do is complete this
figure by putting different bars that
corresponds to the performance achieved
when training with different type of
processes
okay so one one way of training a neural
network to learn about Vision without
having real data is to use simulated
worlds here there are some examples uh
here there are on on the left images
that come from the clever data set and
on on the right images that come from
Minecraft you can use these images in
order to also learn visual
representations
and then we can test how well this
linear these representations do that the
classification task and here they are
clever it's actually better than a
random initialization by but not by much
these images look very different from
real images and the performance doesn't
seem to be that good Minecraft is
capable of achieving much better
performance here is about 41
precondition rate which is like closing
the Gap to real images quite
significantly
but what else can we do this synthetic
walls still require someone generating
that content and that content is
complicated to generate clever is easy
but Minecraft can be quite complicated
to develop
so the question that we have really is
can we learn visual representations by
just looking at noise processes
there is actually a very nice example
that this type of approaches can be
successful which is this work that uses
fractals in order to train visual
representations they use a database of
fractal images
to train visual representations with
different methods and then they test how
well they generalize into the real world
and what we found is that that method
actually does much better for instance
that's clever significantly better than
than using a randomly initialized neural
network and it's around
two-thirds of closing the Gap with the
performance that you get with real data
and the question is can we do better
can you learn to see by just looking at
noise and by noise I don't mean just
white noise like this one I mean noise
with some structure to it but still a
stochastic process
we know from other areas also that
pre-training with noise is actually kind
of just kind of useful sometimes for
instance a parallel work in the language
domain have shown that you can also
train very interesting representations
for natural language understanding by
just using random sets of text nonsense
documents that contain just fake words
are capable of portraying some some
architecture to
fairly well are sub at some simple
language tasks
so in this paper that was led by Manuel
barrard and baradat and this is a
collaboration also with Jonas wolf
tongsu and Philip Isola Philippi Sola so
is also a professional at MIT
so in this paper we want to explore
different ways of generating processes
to teach visual representations
so let me just start with a simple game
here there are six images
three of them are Patches from real ages
and all the other three are patches that
come from noise processes that we have
created
can you guess which ones are what
so let me reveal the answer
here you see which ones are fake which
ones are real and what I'm showing here
is the best one of the bass noise
processes that we have that is capable
of producing images that are stochastic
in nature but that reproduce some of the
properties that are present in real
images
so one example of a very simple
synthetic world that was very popular in
image processing in the 60s is what is
called the deadlifts model these sub set
of images are composed in the following
way
do you generate that image by dropping
the squares at random locations with
random sizes on top of each other
creating occlusions each Square will
have also a random color and it will
create images like the ones I'm showing
here
this was actually a very useful set of
images that was very popular in the 60s
some popular rice in the 90s to study
properties of natural real images so
here there are a bunch of samples from
that particular process you can actually
enhance this process by for instance
also making the squares be in random
orientations and you can also make it
more complex by adding not just squares
but also other shapes like circles
triangles and so on like the images I'm
showing here
so what happens if we train visual
representations using this set of images
well here I'm showing the performances
that you get they work better than
fractals and as you increase the
complexity of these deadliest models
going from squares to oriented squares
to arbitrary shapes random shapes you
get better and better getting fairly
close to the performance that you get
with Minecraft but with a really simple
process this image is you know the code
necessary to describe these images is
very very short
but there are other ways of generating
other processes that have been also very
popular in the computer vision Community
to study natural images one of them is
this remarkable property of natural
images that when you take the Fourier
transform of one image the amplitude
always has this shape of one over F this
property was very popular in TV in
television studies for instance for
compressing signals and so on
and it's been also been quite popular in
developing texture synthesis algorithms
in the 90s where they just study ways of
representing spectral information in
different ways and then sampling from
those processes to generate images that
look like real textures
so we can do that by imposing just some
simple statistics we can look at the
Spectrum of you know we can take random
noise impose that the noise should have
a 1 over F power Spectrum impose some
statistics of wavelet coefficients but
also with what all that also are quite
constrained on natural images they
generally have these uh sparse structure
we can also impose color distribution so
that they look a little bit more like
the deadlifts models but now with really
random and strange shapes and these are
some of the images that get generated by
this particular process again the
process itself is fairly simple to
describe here there are some more images
generated by this process
so now what happens if we train with
this well we get actually better
performance that we were getting with
the deadliest model and now really
really close to the Minecraft
performance
and we can do one final thing also we
also have
another process that we know is very
successful in generating real images and
that's guns we know that this generative
adversarial networks are really
successful at generating images that
look very realistic and part of the
reason why they are successful is
because the neural network contains
already a very useful structural prior
that tells you something about how real
images work
so we can use this to synthesize also
noise but generally what happens is that
when you synthesize images with guns
guns have been trained with real images
and we do not want to use real images at
all so how did you train the gun on the
first place
well you don't train it you just need to
initialize the weights randomly and then
sample from it or use clever
initializations to get more structure
into it and that's what we'll do
so we will just generate different
weights that we know match statistics of
natural images using similar criteria to
the ones I was describing before
so now what happens if you sample from a
gun that is untrained
what happens
these are the images that you get
they look a little bit like the images I
was showing before but now they have a
little bit more structure in fact you
can see some freelyness appearing into
them it's just very shallow but they
seem to look like 3D textures
and if you use these images to train the
system is when you do the best the
performances are actually required quite
close and much better than Minecraft and
closing the Gap significantly with with
real images
and finally another thing that we've
been doing lately is another way of also
generating synthetic data is by using
simple scripts that are capable of
generating processes that look very
interesting visually but are not real
these are processes that are called
shaders and it's short generative
programs written in opengl and they are
capable of synthesizing images that have
some interesting textural properties
generally these are videos that they
generate
and actually if we use a data set of
images generated through these processes
but by using a large collection of
different processes we get a really good
performance
closing the Gap why
why dramatically with respect to real
images
and all performing all of the other
methods quite a lot
in fact is quite actually quite
interesting to look at the nearest
neighbors so the first row so the
problem with what I was describing
before is that we were using
classification and still classification
needed to be trained but you can use
those visual representations just to
collect nearest neighbors and then just
evaluate how good is the system at using
those visual representations to compute
similarities between images in that case
there is no training whatsoever
so the first row here is showing the
nearest neighbors for the query images
image that I'm showing on the left when
you use a Network that has been randomly
initialized so here you can see that the
neighbors actually they don't look at
all like the input image that is a
little a little bit of a similarity
maybe on the pose of the object but
that's about it
the second row shows what happens when
the visual representation has been
trained with a style gun so these are
the five nearest neighbors of the fatata
set of several a hundred thousand images
and you can see that now at least two of
those five images already contain
parrots
and this is the third row is the
neighbors that we get when you train
with this data set made of shaders these
little programs that are capable of
synthesizing processes that look look
interesting but not real
and finally the last road is just
showing the neighbors that you get when
you train with real images and you can
see the shaders in this case was
remarkable and it was really well and it
has never seen a real image this visual
similarity has never seen a single real
image here is another example with a
different query image this is what
happens when you train you know with a
random Network it's capable of getting
like the the Blackness of the original
picture but nothing else a style gun is
now capable of producing pretty nice
neighbors the shaders also and finally
places also gets pretty good neighbors
here is another
um set of examples here each row
represents a particular query and then
what you get with random with a random
Network or when you train with shaders
and you can see the shaders are capable
of capturing visual similarities quite
well
so what we are showing is that by
getting by building these processes our
goal is to be able to develop a process
that is completely synthetic that has
never seen a real data that it doesn't
even contain real content it's not a
virtual world that tries to reproduce
the real world these are just stochastic
processes that generate images that look
interesting but are not real
and our goal is to get rid of images and
labels in order to train visual visual
systems
so we hope that you know the evolution
of computer vision data sets that has
been looking always into building larger
and larger data sets will now become
another Trend we'll have another Trend
where we will start looking into smaller
and smaller synthetic data sets that are
capable of reproducing the performance
of the original data sets of real data
sets
so with that I will stop here thank you
for your attention